y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
responder a una pregunta muy antigua o
al menos una pregunta interesante para
mí digamos que tengo una plataforma o un
precipicio o un edificio
y tiene una altura h
este esta plataforma o este edificio
una altura h
y lo que quiero saber es si por ejemplo
yo estuviera aquí arriba
y quisiera lanzarme por este precipicio
aunque es algo que bueno no es muy
recomendable o quisiera yo lanzar
no sé una piedra
si yo quisiera lanzar esta piedra
por encima de esto
qué velocidad tendría
justo antes de dar contra el suelo este
objeto que estoy lanzando
bueno y como en los vídeos anteriores
vamos a asumir que la resistencia del
aire es cero y de hecho para distancias
pequeñas y objetos pequeños está
asunción es razonable no hay aire vamos
a ponerla aquí en nuestras condiciones
no hay resistencia al aire
no hay resistencia
al aire
y si quieren ser muy puristas pues poder
imaginar que esto se está realizando en
la superficie lunar donde en efecto no
hay nada de aire
y bueno vamos a pensar un poco sobre
esto justo el momento de soltar la
piedra en este instante su velocidad
inicial es igual a cero esta piedra está
está estacionaria
y de nuevo vamos a usar la conversión de
que las cantidades
positivas indican que la velocidad la
dirección va a ser hacia arriba y las
cantidades negativas se indican que la
dirección va a ser hacia abajo
entonces si soltamos esto cuando
lleguemos al fondo justo antes de que
caiga pues va a tener una velocidad
final no sabemos cuál es eso es lo que
queremos averiguar
y además sabemos que como esto bueno
esto ocurre en la tierra
aquí ya no aplica que sea la superficie
lunar porque la superficie lunar tiene
una aceleración gravitatoria diferente
pero si estamos en la tierra conocemos
que la aceleración es una aceleración
constante y es igual a menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
entonces
dada la conversión tenemos aquí que esto
es negativo va hacia abajo y la
velocidad final el vector velocidad
final es una tiene su dirección hacia
abajo por lo que también esta velocidad
final va a ser un valor negativo así que
lo que queremos calcular es la velocidad
final teniendo una altura h
una aceleración constante - 9.8 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y una
velocidad inicial igual a cero
el punto de este vídeo es que vean que
estas fórmulas pueden deducirse usando
cosas básicas que ya conocemos de los
vídeos anteriores hemos visto la fórmula
del desplazamiento
que el esparcimiento es igual a la
velocidad promedio
x
el cambio en el tiempo
de hecho bueno esta es la fórmula tal
cual
qué es la velocidad promedio la
velocidad promedio también la hemos
visto en los vídeos anteriores la
velocidad promedio si tenemos una
aceleración constante que este es el
caso pues va a ser igual a lo que es la
suma de mi velocidad inicial
más mi velocidad final
y esto pues el promedio de estas dos se
divide entre dos bueno el promedio es
sumar estos y dividirlos entre dos esa
es mi velocidad promedio
entonces vamos a ir poniéndolo aquí con
una fórmula del desplazamiento
la velocidad promedio viene siendo esto
velocidad inicial más
velocidad final
entre 2
y cuál es el cambio en el tiempo bueno
vimos que el cambio en el tiempo esta
parte es igual a el cambio de velocidad
voy a cambiar el color para mantenerlo
congruente va a ser el cambio de la
velocidad
/ la aceleración
y esto viene de una fórmula que vimos
anteriormente que es la velocidad del
cambio de la velocidad es igual a la
aceleración por el cambio en el tiempo
entonces aquí
despejamos el cambio en el tiempo
dejamos solo este término nos queda esto
y esto es bueno nuestro cambio en tiempo
es esta parte de nuestra velocidad
promedio es esto
de las condiciones iniciales sabemos que
nuestra velocidad inicial
es igual a cero
entonces nos queda aquí que el
desplazamiento
es igual a mi velocidad
final
entre 2
y esto lo voy a multiplicar por
este término pero el cambio en velocidad
también tenemos qué
esto también es igual al cambio en la
velocidad
es igual a la diferencia de velocidad de
mi velocidad final
las restas de mi velocidad final menos
menos
velocidad inicial
esta es la diferencia de velocidades
pero de nuevo mi velocidad inicial es
cero entonces este cambio esta delta b
viene siendo igual a velocidad final
entonces esto es igual a la velocidad
final
/
aceleración constante y pues parece que
ahora tenemos toda nuestra fórmula en
términos de las cosas que conocemos
vamos a despejar un poco esta parte me
queda entonces que el desplazamiento
es igual a velocidad final por velocidad
final pues me queda que es mi velocidad
final
al cuadrado
dividida
entre dos veces la aceleración lo que
quiero conocer la velocidad final
entonces voy a tratar de dejar este
término o esta variable sola por lo que
ahorita lo que quiero es pasar esta
parte o multiplicar ambos términos por
dos
multiplicado por la aceleración si yo
multiplico ambos términos por
y aquí 2 aceleración
estos se van a cancelar y me va a estar
quedando
2 por la aceleración por el
desplazamiento es igual a mi velocidad
final al cuadrado
y bueno qué es lo que voy a hacer pues
aquí
y porque me interesa velocidad final no
velocidad final al cuadrado pues voy a
sacar la raíz cuadrada de esto
pero bueno vamos a ver ya tenemos
nuestra fórmula aquí quedaría que
nuestra velocidad final sería igual
y en este caso la raíz cuadrada
de dos por la aceleración por el
desplazamiento
nota importante
aquí
voy a tener una cantidad que va a ser
positiva porque en este caso no tengo
una raíz cuadrada de algo negativo sin
embargo como la dirección de mi vector
final va a ser hacia abajo
este resultado tengo que tenerlo con
signo negativo para indicar la dirección
del vector
veamos ahora cuál es mi desplazamiento
mi s pues ustedes pueden decirme ah pues
el desplazamiento es h el valor de h
pero el desplazamiento es un vector
hacia donde está ocurriendo el
desplazamiento el desplazamiento mi
vector desplazamiento está ocurriendo
hacia abajo entonces este valor h no va
a ser h así él solito va a ser menos h
por lo que mi fórmula
ya sustituyendo estos valores valor
final es igual a la raíz cuadrada
todos por la aceleración
x
mi desplazamiento que es menos h
aquí está la raíz cuadrada de esto y
bueno cuál es mi aceleración aquí mi
aceleración es menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo entonces esto es igual a 2 x
menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo
por menos h la altura debe de estar en
metros para que las unidades puedan ser
congruentes y nuestro resultado sea
correcto por menos h
entonces esto viene siendo igual 2 haber
estos menos por menos da más entonces
esta cantidad va a ser positiva 2 por
9.8 va a ser igual a
19.6
las unidades como h va a estar en metros
van a ser metros cuadrados sobre
segundos al cuadrado
por el valor de h
y esta va a ser buena esta cantidad de
la raíz cuadrada y esto es igual a mi
velocidad final
bueno como les comenté este resultado
tiene que ser un valor negativo para
indicar la dirección del vector final
que es hacia abajo
podemos simplificar esto quitando estas
unidades que están dentro de esta raíz
cuadrada y así mi fórmula de la
velocidad final
me quedaría completamente en función de
la altura me queda a
19.6
multiplicado
por la altura
y esto sus unidades son
metros sobre segundo porque como estaban
al cuadrado dentro de esta raíz al
momento de sacarlos pues vemos que ya
les aplique la raíz cuadrada y quedan
metros sobre segundo
entonces bueno ya tenemos la fórmula
esta es la fórmula que estábamos
buscando para obtener la velocidad vamos
a ponerle valores para probarla vamos a
imaginarnos que nuestra altura con
nuestra h
en este caso va a ser igual a 5 metros
que sería más o menos la altura de un
edificio de un piso aunque antes de que
se me olvide no pierdan de vista que
esta cantidad es negativa vamos a usar
la raíz negativa de este resultado para
indicar correctamente la dirección del
vector final si esta altura la h es 5
voy a tener entonces que la velocidad
de este objeto que deje caer
en caída libre va a ser igual a
el valor negativo que me resulte de
sacar la raíz cuadrada
19.6
multiplicado
por 5
y esto va a ser igual
- raíz cuadrada del 98 pueden hacer los
cálculos con su calculadora para
verificar que efectivamente estoy
haciendo bien mis operaciones aquí y
esta raíz va a ser más o menos entonces
igual a menos
9.9 y las unidades son metros sobre
segundo esta va a ser mi velocidad final
de un proyectil que yo dejé caer sin
resistencia al aire de una altura de 5
metros
9.9 metros sobre el segundo en la
dirección hacia abajo que es algo
bastante veloz y así pueden usar esta
fórmula para calcular la velocidad final
de algo que cae si esto está cercano a
la superficie terrestre y no hay
resistencia al aire